hi my name is lania i'm nine years old
and today i will have two
chefs competing to make my dream dish
hi linea hi i'm alex i'm maria
nice to meet you nice to meet you too so
what would unicorn
eat for dinner she would eat maybe like
potato skins but it wouldn't be a potato
okay
it would be a tiger fur it may not sound
that good but unicorns like that
she started off with potato skins and i
was feeling pretty good
and then she threw in that tiger fur
so inside will be cheese
and then we'll have like sweet lollipop
flavored bacon on top
it's sweet but it has bacon on top
and it's all over the place now i love
bacon
okay especially when it's nice and
crispy um
to drink they would have leprechaun
tears
why are they crying the leprechaun is
crying because while the unicorns are
going to drink their tears
oh no nothing goes to waste in unicorn
land
leprechaun tears super straightforward
the unicorn that i met she actually
lives with me now
and her name is pinkie pie pinkie pie
compared to a dog or a cat it's a lot of
work to have a unicorn
they would have this pink steak uh-huh
that is sweet it wouldn't be
like a steak that we eat why it's a
flavor
pink strawberry is that your favorite
fruit yes
me too i'm trying to keep calm but i am
freaking out inside i do not know
what i'm going to make this meal is
served
on a bed of lettuce lettuce it's also
sweet oh
let us see it's just a lettuce lettuce
is just a lettuce okay i always tell her
she needs to eat her vegetables
she can't just have sweet stuff all day
oh wow you're such a great friend
so lynette do you think we can make you
this unicorn meal
yes high five
[Music]
all right so here's what i'm gonna do
for the pink steak i'm gonna make a
blondie
that's strawberry flavored for the
potato skin i'm going to try to shape a
rice krispie treat and then
use orange colored white chocolate for
the tiger fur for the leprechaun tiers
i'm going to make a vanilla
milkshake and diet green for pink steak
i'm going to make
pancakes stack them up with cream cheese
frosting and strawberries
for potato skin i'm going to use root
vegetable chips
and marshmallow how about with frosting
and chocolate for leprechaun tears i'm
thinking about
some green matcha milkshake i'm going to
top with
cookie shaped like four-leaf clover
because that's likely called lucky charm
well i hope this meal isn't too unicorny
all right then i have another idea for
cookie
i got this flower hot shape and i can
just decorate
so it kind of looks like clover i love a
good blondie
linea mentioned that she really likes
strawberries and that she also wanted a
pink steak
i felt like a strawberry blondie would
be perfect because
it will have that pink color but it will
also taste like strawberries which is
something she really likes
this is definitely something i would
have requested when i was nine years old
i like having kale smoothies chicken
alfredo
strawberries anything with strawberries
just not
sushi or like pizza that's disgusting
i'm gonna start with candied bacon
i'm making this mixture brown sugar and
maple syrup together
i'm going to brush onto the bacon i'm
gonna just use
all the method so i don't need to you
know
worry about it i'm gonna start on my
rice krispie treats rice krispies are
great because
not only do kids love them but they're
super malleable my hope
is that i'm going to be able to shape my
rice krispies into like a potato skin
shape
the only thing that i'm really going to
have to think about doing is
this tiger fur i feel like something is
off in these
i might have messed up the ratio i can't
believe i'm messing up rice krispie
treats
it's like the easiest thing to make i
added in
more of the rice krispies cereal this
feels
a little bit better to me already
hopefully
i'm able to shape it looks like potato
thanks i'm making pancake butter right
now because you want to rest the butter
at least 30 minutes i was talking and i
forgot how
many how many flowers i added so i'm
gonna just do it again i don't want that
don't do it again just go with it just
go with it i'm adding pink
photo coloring i like this color it's
like a dreamy unicorn color
so now i'm gonna make my candied bacon i
think mine is a little bit simpler than
hers i'm just going to do
brown sugar and cinnamon and coat that
in the bacon and bake it it'll taste
good
either way my bacon is done in the oven
it's still a little bit
not crispy as i want it and i just taste
it
it's not as sweet i want it so i'm gonna
just chop it up
and coat with more brown sugar so my
cookie is in the oven
while i'm waiting i'm going to make
royal icing
so i can decorate the cookie i want to
dye it with
green because that is going to be
on peppercorn tears drink all right so
my cookie spread it completely
i'm gonna just cool it and think of
something else
my bacon was baking for a long time and
it still didn't really get that
crispy but i don't want it to burn so i
might just have to go with it i hope she
forgot that she likes crispy
i also pulled out my blondies definitely
got a little brownie
i'm just gonna have to try to trim the
edges
into the shape of a steak which is
something i have never done before
it's a little bit trickier than i
thought it was going to be cutting this
blondie into the steak shape
it's a little crumbly in texture but i'm
just trying to go with it
looking at the inside that's pink i'm
happy with that
so now for my grill marks
we did it i think that looks pretty good
i still didn't know what i was doing
and um i just wanted to make look like
something
like a tiger for her so i came up with
skewers
three marshmallows together and stick
the pretzel this
is gonna be my tiger
[Music]
can you show it what's orange i thought
it was yellow
oh that's orange i don't like using food
color but
tons of kids love color so my heart's a
little aches but
you know i have to do but to win it's
kind of look like tiger tygono skewers
i think the pink steak is gonna be the
hardest
and also the tiger for potato skins i
don't know how they're gonna do
that but hopefully it'll be good i've
basically made all the components
now i just need to decorate so i've
melted down my
chocolates i am going to be dyeing my
white chocolate
orange i'm going to try to dip my
baked potato i'm just kind of playing
around trying to get
some kind of fur texture i hope i earned
my tiger stripes
does that look like a tiger yeah it's
like a tiger and a pork pines
child well that's all right i guess
i've never done pancake before but what
i'm trying to do is make a steak shaped
pancake
i'm just hoping my hand won't be shaky
that's like hoping the sky won't be blue
really
i'm cooking lower temperature and hoping
the color
doesn't turn brown yes pink
so i picked out this glass to use for my
leprechaun tier milkshake because
i feel it was like kind of cute and
leprechauny i don't know what that means
but
what i'm gonna try to do is pipe around
the edge of a glass with this green
white chocolate to make a sort of like a
teardrop shape
i have some edible gold glitter and i'm
going to
try to get this on here because every
leprechaun
needs its pot of gold that worked i got
some
stuff in your pancake what you sabotage
me
okay so my pancake is almost done i'm
going to start decorating
i'm going to top with the cream cheese
frosting
and layer the pancake she also asked for
a bed of lettuce
but i don't think it's gonna taste good
if i put lettuce underneath of the cake
so
i will try to incorporate that idea
but still figuring out that reminds me
she asked for lettuce i'm gonna give her
lettuce my interpretation of potato skin
is the potato chips
i'm going to put underneath and sprinkle
on top and
don't forget the bacon bits milkshakes
are
super simple so i'm just gonna put in
some ice cream
some milk and then a little bit of green
food dye
and that should do it
so i'm gonna put a little bit more of
that gold dust
on top so good luck
i'm going to make a replica tears
milkshake with matcha ice cream and i
think i'm going to add some white
chocolate
so it doesn't taste like a lot of matcha
flavor all right
once again yeah nice job i guess it's
time to
trot on over to unicorn land okay
i'm actually super happy with how my
dish turned out
everything looks pretty accurate to the
picture and
i also think it's gonna taste pretty
great overall my dish looks pretty cool
my tiger file looks pretty awesome and
in my mind that's what unicorns eat
[Music]
looks pretty much exactly the same it
looks amazing
[Music]
this is delicious it's very sweet like i
said
i love the chocolate syrup
what did they put on here to make this
sweet
this tastes really good tastes like
syrup
yes looks beautiful
tastes just like leprechaun tears i mean
if you look at the drawing and then you
look at this
you can't tell the difference she likes
it she likes it
what are your impressions here just
looking at this one speechless
this looks amazing
i love how it tastes it's just that this
doesn't really look
like the potato skin that i drew this
pink steak
kind of looks like um pancakes instead
of a steak
let me go ahead and try this
delicious i love it i love how the
strawberries taste just everything on
this
is just delicious
it's very tasty but again i don't see
a cookie in my drawing leprechaun tiers
with no cookie
[Music]
that's i'm getting like a tea and a
milkshake
in one drink it's really delicious
everything
on this plate is just amazing i did not
see this coming
[Music]
so it's time to decide yeah which meal
do you think a unicorn would eat for
dinner first of all
i would like to know whose dish was who
we aren't going to tell you
the lucky winner is
the one with the chocolate syrup and
[Music]
i can't believe i pulled this off
i'm shook i think alex won because
mine's
a little bit abstract i think chef alex
congratulations thank you
i love it i'm gonna hang it up on my
wall
just like a unicorn only has one horn
there can only be one winner in this
competition
and i'm glad it's me
[Music]
you